un sujet qui est vraiment là encore
devrait vous faire réagir puisque on va
partir au royaume uni où une loi
concernant les victimes de viol fait
polémique
et pour cause bourdin direct vous
explique tout cela et on en revient on
revient pour en parler juste après les
victimes de viol doivent désormais
autorisé la police à accéder à leurs
données personnelles sur leurs appareils
électroniques
alors c'est à dire tous leurs sms les
emails les photos les données de leurs
comptes facebook ou instagram installés
sur leur smartphone alors sinon tout
simplement l'enquète est abandonnée des
associations dénoncent elles estiment
que cela revient à traiter des victimes
de viols comme des suspects et surtout
ça risque de les dissuader de porter
plainte mais alors plus de 80% des
victimes sont des femmes
en france 35 % ont entre 18 et 29 ans
qu'est ce qu'on pense de cette idée du
royaume uni qui serait donc de cette loi
qui veut que l'on puisse maintenant
aller farfouiller sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les portables des victimes
pour pouvoir entamer une même procédure
si la victime là où en tout cas la
supposée victime refuse n'y a pas d'
enquêtes ça tombe à l'eau mal pris des
pires idées mais au monde c'est à dire
que qui a pu penser à ça pour moi c'est
extrêmement grave
moi la personne qui touche à mon
téléphone n'y a pas un policier après un
chroniqueur il ya personne qui prends
mon téléphone et jacno à farfouiller le
jean petit côté bien a dit sa ferme et
on me regarde dans les yeux je ne
voulais pas fumer mois 1 personne mais
en vrai c'est déjà compliqué pour une
agression d'aller porter plainte
on passe déjà pour quelqu'un est ce que
ce sont nous dévoile à moi je me suis je
me suis fait agresser réellement a pris
à la gorge comme ça quand je suis allé
porter plainte on va dire à bout vous a
pris à la gorge je comprends pas vous
n'avez pas de trace ah bah non pardon
scemama j'y retourne du coup pour me
faire bien des marques sur le visage
donc ces deux ans est décédé après
traumatisant pour la dcri malric et
traumatisant pour les victimes
donc ce qu'il faut c'est vraiment
encourager les gens à porter plainte et
pas les positionne effectivement comme
des comme des suspects numéro un en ciel
d'août et de éventuellement leurs
paroles on se demande en plus ça c'est
que quand même un crime très particulier
c'est qu'en est il du viol hélas ce qui
ce qui sous-entendrait que peut-être si
on farfouille sont les réseaux et qu'on
estime que la la victime à la cuisse
légère ou qu'elle pose un peu dénudée au
machin se serait pas forcément un
violent face est assez moi je trouve ça
assez étonnant et bien sûr complètement
favorable à cette procédure et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi parce que
certes tu as raison d'une certaine
manière caroline c'est à dire que c'est
déjà une épreuve effectivement d'avoir
que d'avoir subi ce genre de crime c'est
aussi une épreuve de devoir confier son
téléphone portable aux enquêteurs
sachant qu'on sait pas forcément ce
qu'on va y trouver dedans il peut y
avoir des choses compromettantes et du
coup on va peut-être hésité à le donner
ça je comprends
en revanche si je me mets à la place du
suspect et bien c'est une mesure qui
peut le protéger lui aussi parce qu'il
peut être aussi il faut aussi l'admettre
il peut être accusé à tort et le fait de
l'imaginer pas moi pardon mais ma
premier alors je devrais pas prendre
parti c'est à vous prendre parti aura
normalement mais j'imagine tout de même
que la première réaction c'est de
l'image de dire bah écoutez cette fille
elle quand même à la des moeurs un peu
légère visiblement à la guiche et ce
monsieur mais pardon il peut avoir eu
envie et puis au dernier moment dire non
et quand on dit non au dernier moment ça
reste un viol bien sûr si on a dit avant
oui je suis content mais dis donc
cette mesure permet d'établir un
contexte et c'est un faisceau d'indicés
faits sont parfois peut-être de preuve
qu'il peut laisser penser que le suspect
est coupable ou alors est innocent c'est
ce qu'est le haut niveau il vous n'y
voyez pas de dérives possibles ge est
peut-être un frein au dépôt de plainte
parce que c'est une pièce qui est donné
aux mains de la justice est justement
moi je crois au bon fonctionnement de la
justice et je pense que ça peut
justement aider au bon fonctionnement de
l'enquêté mais je vous vois assez pensé
en venant c'est dramatique parce que on
quand on sait que seulement 9% des
femmes victimes de viols vont porter
plainte alors qu'on va leur dire
attention si vous portez plainte va
prendre votre téléphone
ce chiffre va encore diminuer alors
qu'il est déjà dramatique et sur ces 9 %
simplement un homme sur dix qui sera
condamné donc je pense et caroline l'a
dit à demi-mot que on fait ce genre de
choses parce que la plupart des victimes
de viol sont des femmes
si ç'avait été des hommes jeu ça ne
viendrait jamais à l'idée de ces
messieurs de dire on va créer ce genre
de loi à l'heure où on est on pas de
libération de la parole libération de la
femme mouvement mitu balances ton port
je pense que c'est une vraie régression
et l'homme à la base qui est ce il est
présumé innocent et la femme en donnant
ces informations elle est présumé
coupable de mentir et donc on passe de
l'agresseur a finalement la menteuse
l'hystérique la provocatrice comme vous
l'avez dit elle a donné son facebook
qu'elle était peut-être en position un
peu dénudée bizarre et alors elle a le
droit ou pas pour autant qu'elle
méritait ce viol donc je pense que c'est
très dangereux je suis étonné que les
britanniques aient pris cette décision
j'espère que ça ne va pas chez nous mais
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi
jimmy et tu as parlé la libération de la
parole féminine et tu as raison et c'est
une bonne chose néanmoins
et aussi des dérives et je pense que
cette mesure est un gars de vous faire
ce qu on sait qu il ya des délais on l'a
vu récemment avec des personnes connues
comme pierre palmade par exemple on l'a
vu également avec n'est pas réglée alors
typiquement vous prenez cet exemple la
maison sans plus ce pauvre pierre
palmade qui a été jeté en pâture en
disant qu'il avait eu l'effet etc en
l'occurrence les policiers n'ont pas eu
besoin d'avoir accès au téléphone depuis
retour après six jours à vérifier qu il
s agissait d une fausse accusation donc
vous voyez je suis d'accord avec vous
mais j'ai le sentiment qu'on voit de
plus en plus d'affaires ou finalement
des personnes sont accusées à tort
d'avoir commis des viols et on se trouve
on se retrouve finalement que des
affaires classées on peut prendre mais
quand vous mettez en même temps
l'opposition de d'éventuels menteuse que
quelqu'un toute fatigue qui vient en
tant que victime voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est qui me chagrine mois jusque
dans et on crée pas une loi pour
l'exception l'exception dans les viols
ou ce serait la femme turai menti ça
reste une exception dont va pas
légiférer
sophie chose qui est rare légiférons sur
des choses qui fréquentent les femmes
victimes de viols doivent être protégés
les condamne heures les agresser les
agresseurs doivent être condamnés fin de
l'histoire mais rappelons que certaines
victimes de viols en général ont déjà un
espèce de sentiment de culpabilité
elle se disait ce que moi j'ai pas fait
quelque chose est-ce que je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas regardé je leur ai pas guichet
à ce que tout cela on leur indique très
clairement
ben oui en fait c'est un peu de votre
faute c'est même carrément de votre
faute et on va aller le vérifier et on
va trouver des preuves contre vous et
dans ce cas là vous ne serez plus la
victime mais vous serez voilà la
personne qui a instigué ça et donc ça on
n'y croyait pas saddam est rarement
parce que je pense que vous voyez aussi
la chose à l'envers c'est à dire ça peut
aussi protéger la victime présumée en
l'occurrence puisque si la personne a
envoyé des messages à caractère sexuel
si elle était très lourde dans ses
messages ça peut aussi être une mesure
qui protège la victime en prouvant bien
que finalement il ya eu harcèlement en
amont du viol voyez il ya aussi des deux
parties donc je pense que vous voyez le
verre à moitié vide c'est à la victime
de décidé de montrer les messages
qu'elle a reçues et non pas la police à
dire tu me les montre pour être sûr que
tu étais pas en train de mentir un viol
c'est pas parce c'est très dur à vivre
jeune damien et donc d'être retrouvée
face à des policiers qui te vois plus
comme une agression
aucune victime n'a cessé en tout cas
sachez qu'en france il ya seulement 12 %
1 des victimes de viol ou tentative de
viol qui qui en portait plainte et qui
ont ensuite maintenu leur plainte vous
imaginez seulement 12%
l'accès aux données des victimes de viol
on vous a posé la question est ce que
vous êtes pour ou est ce que vous
trouvez cela scandaleux et bien voyez
damien vous êtes un petit peu seul sur
ce coup-là suffit pour cent
nos téléspectateurs vous suivez les 72 %
sans doute le peloton cela scandaleux
effectivement ça reflète vos avis sur le
plateau